ce sont les routes du futur intelligente
connecter avec une performance
énergétique efficiente des
infrastructures développées ici au
campus scientifique et technique de
colas à magny les hameaux
une centaine de collaborateurs engagés
sur trois sujets la transition
environnementale la transformation
énergétique et numérique
c'est le cas de ce passage piéton
autonome en expérimentation à mandelieu
la napoule nantes ou encore dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris ce passage
piéton représenté par les bandes
blanches et lumineux une capacité en
fait à pouvoir s'illuminer au moment du
passage d'un piéton qui détecte et de
manière automatique par une caméra
thermique
la deuxième techno qui est combinée dont
qui sont les surfaces noires sont en
fait des cellules photovoltaïques ce qui
permet donc de capter l'énergie solaire
de la transformer en énergie électrique
et donc d'alimenter les bandes blanches
en led
en déplacement à magny les hameaux le
ministre délégué des transports jean
baptiste djebbari a pu découvrir
l'ensemble des innovations développées
par colas aujourd'hui était une bonne
étape pour s'apercevoir à la fois de
l'état de l'art sur le plan du
développement technologique et puis de
l'effort qui nous restent collectivement
à faire avec les collectivités les
acteurs privés
les organismes de recherche parce que
c'était fort avec l'état il est
évidemment un partenariat les collectifs
la présence du ministre l'occasion pour
les professionnels des infrastructures
routières de rendre plusieurs
propositions pour améliorer le
déploiement des innovations c'est
simplifier et rendre accessible à un
maximum de collectivités on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui sur le terrain est bien
souvent tellement hors de plus petites
communes aussi assez souvent
s'il n'a pas la compétence intrinsèque
dans son administration
eh bien il n'est pas toujours au fait de
ce qui peut faire comment le faire
comment le financer la poursuite du
développement des innovations dans ce
secteur
un travail collectif entre l'état les
collectivités les grands groupes et les
start up